Hey youtubers it’s Charlie and recently
a new monster was spotted on the set of Series
8.
Don’t you just love it when they film outdoors.
We don’t know who he is or what he’s all
about, but fans that were on the set that
day started calling him “The Mole” just
because his claws look like they’re used
for digging.
But it gives us a great excuse to talk about
the top 10 monsters we’d like to see come
back.
I love how when you see him walking around
like this it makes it look like he’s just
interrupting someone’s picnic in Cardiff.
In related news, I’ve also got details on
some of the episodes and there’s a special
Doctor Who thing happening in April on the
Horror Channel.
So I’m going to do two separate videos for
those.
And a new Q&A video.
Be sure to subscribe to get them if you’re
finding me for the first time.
I’ll try to post them in the next week.
So here’s the top 10 monsters I’d like
to see come back.
Number 10 - The Beast.
Easily one of the biggest if not scariest
monsters.
He claimed to have existed since before the
normal universe existed.
And something about the way they’ve been
using the cracks makes me feel like ancient
old things, including the time lords, will
try to use them to coming back.
Digital effects have evolved a lot since we
last saw him in series 2, but they did use
him again in a comic story where he escaped
to earth to try and get revenge on the 10th
Doctor.
One of the few thing really old monsters like
this are good for, aside from killing people,
is ancient knowledge.
I’m really hoping the Doctor has a few good
Sherlock-style mysteries to solve.
Clueing for looks all over time and space
just sounds like a lot of fun.
Number 9 - The Ice Warriors
The last time we saw Grand Marshall Skaldak
in Series 7 he was being rescued.
We don’t know where they went, which means
they’re still at large.
Even though the last time we saw him he was
having his Captain America de-thawed moment
it’s possible that they Doctor could enlist
the aide of Skaldak to fight in a battle or
two.
Not all of Doctor Who’s monsters are villains.
Despite evidence to the contrary.
Number 8 - The Great Intelligence.
Another ancient pre-universe character.
We never really got a definitive answer as
to whether or not the Great Intelligence was
really destroyed when it tried to enter the
Doctor’s timestream.
Being so ancient and omniscient I find it
hard to believe that it would be destroyed
so quickly.
Number 7 - The Reapers.
As much as the Doctor messes with the space
time continuum, I’m surprised they haven’t
come back sooner.
The cracks are more of a tear in space than
a tear in time, so those wouldn’t necessarily
bring them back, but it does seem like the
Doctor crosses his own time stream at least
once every series.
Number 6 - The Pyroviles from The Fires of
Pompeii
How great would it be for The Doctor and Clara
to revisit Pompeii in some way, or at least
visit somewhere that allows them to come back,
just as a nice nod to Capaldi’s other character
from that episode.
Plus it would be a fun nod to Karen Gillan
too.
I don’t expect her to cameo again until
the next anniversary special, but any reference
to the original episode would be a subtle
reference to her character from before she
was cast as Amy Pond.
There are a lot of rumors flying around that
Series 8 will pay some homage to Fires Of
Pompeii, but I haven’t seen any confirmation.
There has been a nice fan made poster though.
Number 5 - The Spiders including A New Great
One
Originally seen in Planet of The Spiders,
this just sounds like it would be fun a la
Martin Freeman had with the spiders of Mirkwood
during The Hobbit.
Those spiders were much bigger than the ones
in planet of the spiders.
But I just love the imagery they evoke.
And the idea that at least in the original
story a giant spider queen is trying to ascend
to a higher state of existence.
I think if they did make it back into a story
it would be something less cosmic.
If series 8 is supposed to have a horror driven
tone, then I think spiders just building a
large lair feeding on people would be enough.
Number 4 - The Great Old Ones, who were from
classic who, but got a shout out during the
series 7 finale.
They’re another pre-universe monster and
are really more effective as an idea, like
the great intelligence, acting through different
physical bodies.
In classic who, their biology actually differed
quite a bit between members of the race, but
they had the power to fundamentally change
the properties of the universe.
I think of them as being an inspiration for
the Q Continuum on Star Trek.
So when you think of them, imagine a more
sinister version of John DeLancie.
And instead of Patrick Stewart, imagine the
seventh doctor.
Number 3 - The Rest of The Pre-Universe Creatures.
I already mentioned The Beast and The Old
Ones, but there are more things that existed
before the creation of our universe, the N-Universe.
Some of them like the ones I just mentioned
were able to travel into the new universe.
Since the cracks exist all over time and space
now.
I’m expecting other things besides the Time
Lords to use them to come in.
That will always be a threat until the Doctor
either undoes the damage from when the cracks
were created.
Remember he rebooted the Universe.
So there’s no easy solution.
Number 2 - The Time Lord Matrix.
Not really a monster, but much more relevant
as an idea given the current state of our
digital existence.
The last big story featuring the Matrix was
during The Ultimate Foe, which also featured
the Valeyard.
If you’re not familiar, the Time Lords use
the Matrix to store all their collected knowledge
and to predict the future.
The Sixth Doctor was actually able to physically
enter it using the key of Rassilon.
Which is kind of funny and makes it seem like
the Wachowski’s totally ripped Doctor Who
off.
Since that movie was made 13 years after Ultimate
Foe.
It’s not just a computer either, it’s
a micro universe.
Kind of like the pocket universe where Gallifrey
exists right now.
I don’t expect to see any more Time Lord
stories until the Doctor communicates with
them again or finds a safer way to restore
them to the normal universe.
And I don’t think that’s going to happen
any time soon.
I do think he’ll speak to them again before
the end of Series 8.
and my number 1 monster I’d like to see
come back - The Valeyard.
The Dark Doctor.
He escaped capture during Ultimate Foe and
while a lot of people think that The Master
is the Doctor’s ultimate foe.
I really think it’s the Valeyard.
Since the Master is more of an anti-hero,
sometimes crazy person.
As opposed to the Valeyard, who I see as more
of a black hat wearing villain.
Who could be a greater enemy to you than your
own self.
So now it’s your turn.
Which Monsters do you want to see Doctor Who
bring back.
As we saw from those behind the scenes pics.
Moffat is creating some new ones, so no matter
what I think series 8 will be a lot of fun.
At least if you enjoy horror stories.
Like I said, I’m working on a Q&A this weekend,
a breakdown of the series 8 episodes and there’s
a special horror channel marathon coming.
So I’m going to do a video for my top 10
favorite scary classic doctor who stories.
Just classic who.
Since series 8 is supposed to largely be inspired
by it.
Right now click here to learn more about series
8 and click here for my next Doctor Who Q&A.
I’ll try to post that later this weekend.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tonight.
High fives!